Hi f 1Hello everyone,
I'm 4 all over the world. Thank you for coming to my seminar today
. It's Alexis Reth Memorial at the Institute of Brain Science, University of Victoria.
Before I get into that, I would like to introduce a paper
published by a female researcher at the Haga Research Institute.
Human memory is the cerebrum.
It can be thought of as a sort of plush memory stored in the cortex, especially in the temporal lobe. The
brain works by transmitting electrical signals between cells called neurons.
Unfortunately, the person who proposed this theory
became an individual at the age of 17.
We have succeeded in building a system that is true to that theory.
[Music
] Instead of creating a pseudo-personality through a program
, as in the past, artificial intelligence is created based on human memories that have been converted into data.
It's a system built on that
.